this is the main Dakota access pipeline
resistance camp
it's where thousands of protesters who
call themselves water protectors have
been living for months and they've been
working day and night to stop this
pipeline they face tear gas pepper spray
rubber bullets and mass arrests and
defensive clean water and sacred sites
when you experience the frontline and
you experience what you're fighting for
and then the harm that it can cause to
others it strikes that fire and you to
remain here and keep that fire burning
not long after we arrived we got word of
an action that'd Apple construction site
these water protectors have run over the
hill to the machinery over there and
stopped the active construction of the
Dakota access pipeline
the 3.8 billion dollar project is nearly
complete dakota access and its parent
company energy transfer partners have
laid down most of the eleven hundred
seventy two miles of pipe which will
carry crude oil across four states all
that's left is to build under the
Missouri River the main source of
drinking water for the Standing Rock
Sioux tribe but the fight is not just
environmental it's a continuation of a
battle tribes have been waging against
colonialism for over 500 years I didn't
have to consider the impacts to sacred
sites to cultural sites to all these
things that people are talking about
this is what we're concerned about this
pipeline is destroying places that can
never be replaced
I spoke to Tara shortly after she got
out of jail I had to bend over and do
all the things and coffee but strip
completely or just I know completely
everything everything everything had to
come off how humiliating did that feel
it was you know pretty degrading
experience there were police officers
that were definitely engaging in very
very threatening behaviors there was a
police officer that was carrying a less
lethal ammunition weapon and he saw his
colleagues kind of look ashamed and
start to look away and he took aim and
aimed directly at my face I was pulled
back and the beam mehron exploded next
to my head I mean they were very much
trying to hurt people and it was a
really scary thing
Stacey John is a Navajo and Dakota vet
whose family lives near the camp she
served as a police officer in the Air
Force the way law enforcement officials
are criminalizing our indigenous people
is really ridiculous the militarization
of police here against our people our
water protectors is just awful coming
from a law enforcement background you
know we go through training bird you
know I've been tased before and I have
been maced before but we go through
these trainings so we know how it feels
so we know in what situations to deploy
these uses of force and then of these
circumstances with these water
protectors have you know validated that
use of excessive force
so it's Julie it's awful seeing that hi
the Morton County Sheriff declined our
requests for an interview and referred
us to statements defending their actions
all the while the resistance camp has
grown
it's the largest gathering of tribes in
recent history and they're ready for a
freezing winter and long fight
Taisha Mitchell is a 25 year old Navajo
she's been camping for several weeks you
have like are like mummified moving bags
you know we have like a Coleman stove
our heater excuse me a Coleman heater
it's not really a lot what is this whole
protest and being here in camping out so
long what does that meant for you on
like an emotional person level if
anything it's been mind-opening to me to
not have false hope that the government
cares and so I don't I don't have that
faith anymore and now I have that faith
in my comrades in my people and the
people I've met out here people have
like mind and the people here are
beautiful
the people here are were called through
indigenous ways but we've also have our
allies here as well you know people who
care about this earth and that's
something that shocks me the most is
that we have no other agenda here we
have no other agenda besides keeping
that water oil-free that's it this is
what evenings look like
water protectors gather around campfires
telling stories and singing we're not
really sovereign sovereign is an
imagination that they want us to like
think you guys are sovereign but really
when it comes down to it we have to go
and get the okay from the government
still and most the time when it's in
development they shut us down that's
what open generation that's why we're
here because we're gonna make a change
in the morning hundreds were back at it
this time blocking a road for
construction vehicles native water
protectors were marching to hold a
prayer ceremony in this happen
this fight will only get tougher a trump
presidency bodes well for the oil and
gas industry Trump himself has invested
between 500,000 and 1 million dollars in
energy transfer partners Brandin iron
Hawk is Lakota from Pine Ridge he's been
camping since August what does the
victory look like to you when I see this
black snake you know get killed when
they get defeated and they can't work on
it no more you know that's the day you
know I think our people will be happy
and you know the government will realize
you know we're not gonna give up so
easily and they should know that by now
because we've been out here for four
months now you know we've been living
through this many moons ago many winters
ago you know this is how our ancestors
split so you know we're not going to
give up easily and we're not gonna we're
not gonna give up on this war between us
and the dapple Workers